[Musik]
ihr ruf ist erkennt märz wieder
wir haben ist und ausgeforscht glück
[Musik]
erstmals grundsätzlich das wird den
oligarchen und ein haufen zeug aber noch
nicht so genau wissen dass es ist und
das werden wir jetzt weiter voran
geschritten
[Musik]
gleich sind streife des plots dort für
die suchzeiten 48 tore wieder okay sagt
wochenvergleich um die aktionäre
das ist für jeden bei jedem hemd oder
leberwurst gleich
[Musik]
nie
also familie war halt dieses highlight
wo man die ganze ausrüstung und wo sie
das erste mal auf tennis wie ist wie
firma die in den ganzen kosten der
einbringer aber schlussendlich mit der
zeit und mit bisher im system kriegt
also diesmal definitiv heitmeier
christian warum
[Musik]